[Music]
city has a new name and a new
perspective can I call you brother can
you call me love love and the 48 year
old rapper who's no stranger to name
changes with honored for his documentary
at Sunday's Hollywood Film Award he had
a vision vision yeah I was like ready to
die yeah
can't stop won't stop was definitely one
of those turning points in my life where
people got a chance to see what I really
do or you know the man and person behind
the myth
et caught up with love backstage after
he received the award and here's what he
had to say about his new lease on life
I'm absolutely living my best life it's
really just in you know my evolution as
a man and
and really tapping into like love and
tapping into tapping into relationship
with God maybe get making that toast and
putting into perspective what really
counts you know you know the more I'm
here to help people I'm here to inspire
and motivate people and when you get
into that groove you know stay in that
groove and just you know be able to
enjoy the blessings of life I don't want
the Chrysler that looks like the Phantom
I want the Finn I've always felt like
that though with you because like you
and you love music you love like luxury
you love all and like when we look at
your life we like this man like can I
can I be part of the bad boys yes yes
yes yeah no it's just a good time you
had you and life you have ups and you
have downs you know so when you're
experienced in a time when you feel
comfortable especially in this industry
it's a good feeling to have that
security within yourself
[Music]
you